So the correct answer--other than refusing to answer the question,
which would be a very correct way to answer such a question--
the correct answer is the third choice.
And there's some ways to know
which ones are not correct.
I'll show you soon how each of these sequences was generated.
Well, if you look at the first one,
you see there's a sequence of 0-1-1-0-1-1 that keeps repeating.
Anything with a repeated pattern like that is definitely not random.
Now, the caveat is certainly if you generated a long enough random sequence,
eventually it would contain this pattern inside.
The other one that is probably the trickiest one--
that when humans generate random sequences
they look sort of like this.
The property that this sequence has is there's never more than three repetitions in a row.
And when humans are asked to generate random sequences,
they usually don' t have long runs of repetition,
but in real random sequences there are.
You can see there's a sequence of five 0s here.
There's a sequence of four 1s. There's lots of repetition.
In this there's never more than two in a row,
so this is not random.
The other two look potentially random.
You'd have to analyze them a little more carefully.
This one has more structure. This one is actually random.
Let me show you--and I have to say,
this one is actually close to random.
And let me show you how each of these was generated.
Here's how I generated each of those sequences.
So the first sequence was generated by generatesequence.
I'll show you what generatesequence does next.
But for each position in the sequence,
the procedure that generates the output generates 0
if the position is divisible by 3,
otherwise it generates 1.
And we do that for the length of the sequence, which is defined as 88.
Display-bits turns a list of bits into a string.
All this code will be available linked from the course.
So that is what generated the first sequence.
And the code for generatesequence is here.
It just maps the function onto the range from 0 to n minus 1.
So for that length, we're seeing the output of the function at every position.
So that's the first one--and clearly non-random.
The second one is taking a string,
converting it into bits, and displaying those bits.
And the string is this great quote from John von Neumann.
And what the quote says is that
"anyone who considers arithmetical methods of producing random digits
is, of course, in a state of sin."
But, of course, we do it anyway.
So definitely, that's not random. It's generated from a very specific string.
If you knew the string and you knew what these procedures do,
you could generate that sequence.
And the sequence that it generates is the one that as the second choice here.
It looks sort of random, depending on how carefully you look at the patterns,
but it's definitely not random, because it comes from this quote from John von Neumann.
The third one is actually designed to be random.
So we're using the Random Choice Method.
That's provided in the PyCrypto library that I'm using to generate random numbers.
It claims to generate fairly good cryptographic random numbers.
So this third sequence at least is generated in a way
that is designed to be random.
The fourth one is generated using this procedure
called generatefakerandom,
which starts by making random choices,
but is designed to trick humans by not having repetitions greater than 2.
And I should change my comment.
I had originally done it with >3,
and that looks to most humans very random.
And I know it was a trick question, but I thought it would be a little too tricky--
including >3.
But this is a good test for humans.
And one of the experiments people sometimes do
is ask humans to come up with a sequence of random numbers--
that they think are random--from their own head,
and they come up with sequences that are easily recognizable as non-random
because they don't like to have too much repetition.